- I think that, that basketball
was some of the best
basketball I will ever see for the rest of my life.
- For sure.
- Do you feel that way?
- For sure. I think
that was the
highest level of basketball being played
because it was only basketball,
and guys were so locked in.
You know, you go to the gym,
you have shootaround,
you eat,
you play.
Win or lose, you,
you're in your room and you go back to the gym.
If you want some fr- if you want to do something,
you want a hobby,
you just go down to the gym.
You have a court time
from 6 to 9.
Like, that was all we did. You know, so,
other than that, you’re playing cards
with your teammates, you know? So, um,
guys were just locked in, though.
So we're always talking about basketball,
we’re always talking about coverages,
we’re always in the gym shooting free throws.
So it was just-
that was the only thing we were doing.
And that helped me, for sure,
because that's the kind of guy I am.
To stay locked in night in and night out.